[Music]
yeah so the us open
is a an annual tournament organized by
the us federation and the weird thing
about the us open is that there's only
one section everybody plays in this well
there's only one section there's no like
under 1600 under 1800 that's why it's
not feeder rated because most of the 16
1700s don't have a feeder rating but
there's three schedules you can play the
nine day the sixth day or the four day
this is the last round today in the
tournament i got seven out of nine i won
the first five i drew the last four
so i was playing
josh shang who is
a gm
he's like maybe 25 20 few days so
obviously i wanted to win this game
pretty badly i was white
okay so i went
mainline
he is a
con player so knight f3 e6
earlier in the tournament i played c3 in
round five and i won a nice game
but i figured he'd prepare for it in the
45 minutes that we had to prepare so i
decided to play open sicilian d4
okay he plays the khan he's josh is a
con player bishop d3 the main lines
bishop c5 knight b3 bishop a7 there's
also bishop e7 there's like two main
moves in this position uh bishop b7
there's this move queen g4 that's
generally played provoking
king's side weakness and then you come
back to e2 white is considered slightly
better in this slide it's complicated
obviously
pros and cons
josh plays bishop a7 so the bishop is
quite nice here which is why
i played something that's pretty popular
nowadays queen e2
97 and then quickly bishop e3 trying to
neutralize black's strongest piece
bishop on a7 so generally in this line
white castle's king's side
but i analyzed her like literally 10
minutes of the engine before the game
and i found that the engine actually
likes
the concept of castling queen side which
is
pretty wild but
i also needed to go for broke this game
so i figured i'd give it a shot
so i played knight c3
he plays b5 and here of course i
confused the
very little amount of prep that i did
the prep that i did i i reached this
position and it was to take on a7 and
then shift the queen up to e3 and play
a4 contesting like challenging black's
pawn chain on the queen side
and then actually castling king's side
but i forgot that and i forgot like in
which positions you were supposed to
cast the queen said so i castled queen
side here
which is not bad um but it's
not exactly what my prep was
okay so he goes before quickly which is
correct
forcing the knight to decide knight a4
d6
and
this threatens the move bishop d7
which traps the knight on a4 and it
actually looks like white has no
clear way to defend against that
but of course i anticipated this and my
idea was to play e5 this is what i play
to play e5 and e5 is
is a typical move in such positions it
opens up the bishop and mainly it
challenges it challenges the d6 pawn so
he can't take because the bishop takes
h7 was the queen obviously
and if he goes d5 then the knight is now
free it has the c5 square i don't have
to worry about it getting trapped he
probably should have gone d5 i mean here
i was going to go bishop g5 and queen h5
and try to set up a quick quick king
side attack complicated position but
according to the engine black is more
than fine after d5
but after like five minutes he plays
this with bishop d7 this is a losing
move
had i found the correct move here i
would have very likely won the game he
goes bishop d7
and
so so this this attacks the knight on a4
obviously the most obvious move for
white which is the move i ended up
playing
is e takes d6
and there's an interesting idea here
which got me really excited
which is of course black takes the
knight on a4
and one would think that you have to
take on e7 black takes on e7 and
black is okay here
but instead of taking on e7
i have a completely devastating move
here which is bishop e3 to g5
attacking the knight a second time
and i'm threatening he takes e7 of the
fork against the queen and the broken he
still can't take the pawn because again
i have bishop takes h7
this is
this ends the game immediately
this literally ends the game there's
nothing he can do against the thread of
d there's also queen e4 which forks the
pawn and the rook
this is a complete disaster
so this got me excited and then i
briefly had the thought of going bishop
g5 first
bishop g5 first
if he takes on a4 we transpose into that
line
and if he goes d5
then i thought well i have queen h5 here
and i can maybe sack on h6
and this looks really really really
promising why can't he play f6
if he plays f6
i guess we can do it through this move
order if you place f6 i can take on e6
yeah no this is totally crushing rook f7
bishop c4 i mean just look at this
i mean just look at the pieces
how can blacks hope to survive this
um
and if he moves the king then sorry not
with a queen with a pawn
again there's this fork
so this would have been resigns um
but first i don't know why this is a
mystery to me why i didn't play bishop
d5 i saw the move i knew it was
promising
but i just didn't want to think about it
for too long and i decided to play edie
um
turns out the bishop g5 is apparently
plus four
and now
not queen h5 which i was planning to
play is not best
uh simply knight ac5 and queen h5 is
coming next and black's position is
horrendous i mean this would have just
won the game
yeah this is this is terrible
but i was playing queen h5 h6 bishop
takes h6 and apparently this is a lot
less clear
because of this move g6 which i had
missed
and now it's actually pretty much
unclear
would i have won the game of five
players five nobody knows
but
it would have given me a more serious
shot anyways i played he takes d6
um my opponent correctly takes on e3
i take back so again
if he takes my knight then i have this
move quinny for forking
h7 and a8
so he can't he can't take my knight he
has to move his knight he goes knight d5
and at first sight it may seem that i
have blundered
because the queen is attacked and the
knight is still attacked but of course i
have this simple move queen e4
which threatens checkmate on h7 and
forces him to defend and that gives me
time to move my knight into c5
if he goes f5 then i drop my queen back
to e1
this is the nice detail that i spotted
and if he takes my knight then i return
to e6 and i win back the knight of d5
and i'm up two pawns
so so to be completely honest i i
thought f5 was forced
and i completely forgot that he can also
play the move g6 and i had a couple
moments like this in the tournament
where i just like
had a complete mental breakdown i just
like forgot about a very simple move
pretty disturbing stuff i assumed he had
to play f5 here
and that seriously weakens the e6
pawn and it makes the move knight c5 a
lot scarier so somehow i forgot about g6
completely just like escape my mind but
okay knight ac5
and this position looks
unbelievably good for white it looks
almost winning i'm up upon
it's a pawn on d6 the pieces look great
but in fact white has only a very small
advantage according to the engine
and the reason why is this move a5 which
he played and once he played it i
started realizing that the situation was
a lot more complicated than i made it
out to be
because let's say that white just like
ignores
the situation on the queen let's say i
play h4 well then he plays a4
and then he plays a3 and all of a sudden
the c3 square becomes a huge problem
like if you play b3
then he can already play knight c3 here
actually believe it or not
and there's even a rook sack line where
he goes queen b6 and this knight causes
a lot of problems for black
crazy line but black's pieces somehow
coordinate very very nicely and my
knights are totally impotent they're not
attacking anything
they're not attacking anything at all
whereas black's pieces are perfectly
assembled on the queen side
so i saw this line
and i started getting nervous and i had
good reason to get over so i thought let
me get this knight off of b3 so that he
doesn't play a4 with tempo so i
centralized it i played knight c4
now he played another really nice move
queen c8 this is the only move according
to the engine that gives black a decent
position
this forces me
this attacks the knight it forces me to
do something with an i don't have many
things to do with the knight i have to
take on d7
that helps him complete his development
this knight on d5 is just a monster it's
nicely anchored by the pawn
briefly i thought i had a tactic with
knight takes e6
removing the defender
obviously
f takes c6 queen takes c6 check
wins the night back but does anybody see
why this doesn't work what does black
have in this position
see if i can involve the crowd at this
advanced hour
so let's see what people have come up
with
yeah the move is um
yeah yeah everybody got it night
knight five f6
knight five f6 only move again rookie
eight blunders i mean you're not
defending the knight on d5
if you go knight seven f6
and i saw this there's a beautiful
intermezzo d7 you know well what the
hell does this do well if you take with
the queen then you put the queen in the
line of fire of the knight and i take
that fade and i'm attacking the queen
and if you take with a knight well then
you're no longer attacking white's queen
you're also not defending the knight on
d5 now that line gets complicated black
can go queen v8 but here white gets y
gets a strong attack for the knight so
all of this is avoided with knight five
f6 and you you have to move the queen
and then you lose the knight
that was disappointing
okay
so after
i i thought about this for a bit and now
i made another inaccuracy apparently the
best move was actually to go h4 and to
start my own attack
but i thought this was very slow i
didn't even seriously consider it i was
like well blacks can go a4 a3 i have to
do something about it
so i i play them in bishop b5
well my idea was to put a knight on c6
and eventually aim for e7
i felt like
you know
i've got an extra pawn i need to put it
to good use
okay so he moves the knight away to f6
i shift my queen up to e5
and he continues to attack with a4
and this is a big moment so
this is where i officially lost the
threat i think my advantage is basically
gone it's just a very crazy position
at this point i was extremely upset at
myself for not playing bishop g5 to be
honest it was interfering in my thinking
i also realized that black wants to play
a3 and carve out the c3 square and this
will get really really scary really i
could get checkmated in like three moves
here
and my pieces are all suspended in
midair
and nothing seemed to work and it's all
because this knight on d5 is such an
incredible piece it's holding everything
together it's defending f6 it's
defending e7
so apparently
the
best continuation for white would have
been to play knight c6 as i had planned
but the reason i didn't play it is
because of this move queen c8 to b7
attacking the bishop
and if the bishop moves then you lose
the knight
you could give a check on e7 but this
doesn't do anything knight takes c7 d
queen takes c7
that's it you've lost your extra pawn
and black is still attacking
so what else is there to do but
apparently there was a
crazy tactical idea you can take on d5
this i saw but after knight takes c5 i
didn't see a follow up
you know what what now you still 97
isn't checkmate
but there's this quiet move rook h1 to
d1
incredible idea the threat is to take
the other knight and then go 97 and
that's gonna be mate or it's gonna force
black to give up his queen
and the crazy detail is if he takes the
bishop
now you can't take the knight because
then he takes our knight and we have no
more attack
but we have the move97 check
and we win the queen
we win the queen because black is forced
to take
so this doesn't win the game or anything
black can defend the e7 square with his
rook rook fe-8 but apparently it's like
plus one you have to find this knight d4
back
black plays a3 it gets totally wild
uh but objectively this was probably the
best i could have done here to take on
d5 and go rooft when i played rook
what did i play i played uh in this
position i didn't play knight c6
um i played the move rook d3
and my idea was that if he had if he now
plays a3 i wanted to go b3
and i didn't want him to stick a queen
on c3
that was what i was worried about that's
why i played rookie throwing to cover
that square
so i think the idea is pretty healthy
but he found another great move here he
played rook a8 to a5
and he continues to accumulate the
pressure on my position now the now the
bishop is dangling and it's loose
and if you move the bishop then there's
an x-ray against the queen
and i was calculating stuff and i was
like i'm gonna
i felt like i was
totally lost here even though still
maybe with engine like precision i can
hold the balance
the chest.com engine is saying rook hd1
only move
but i saw this and i was like this is
i just didn't see a single move knight
c6 you can no longer play because you
dropped the bishop
i thought about going bishop c6
but then i saw that he has rook c5
attacking the bishop again
it's terrible but what's crazy is that
you've got all these pieces that are in
the center and you've got this extra
pawn on d6 and it's not going anywhere
so eventually i came up with a move a3
uh which looks crazy it's a mistake
obviously it should have been a decisive
mistake but it makes some sense
i was trying to provoke b3 and then i
would
i was actually going to place no no i
wasn't going to play c3 i was going to
play rook d2
um c3 walks into another tactic rook
takes b5
knight b5 and queen c4 so i thought
oh but apparently here there's rook 65
so maybe not maybe not this but
uh there's also queen c5 here which is
pretty devastating
like a catholic seven-year-old that's
very specific anyways i saw rook d2 and
i thought okay i hold everything
together
but i had i completely missed his next
move which was queen c5 and he continues
to move in
and attack my pieces and he's
threatening to take the bishop
so i played a takes b4 and now he simply
plays queen takes b4
and among other things he's threatening
to tear me apart with the move a3
so i'm just getting destroyed here
um
i played the move c4 out of desperation
i knew this was losing
but this also sets a trap if he plays a3
then i have b takes a3
and if he plays rook takes e3 it looks
like white's king is screwed but all of
a sudden you go knight c2 and this is a
fork against the queen and the rook and
he has no checks
but
instead of a3 he finds a very pretty
sacrifice a pretty simple sacrifice
which immediately leads to a totally
decisive attack
does anybody see
what sacrifice
he came up with and after this move it's
like open season on white's king there's
one white's position is being held
together by a tiny string
and it's the bishop on b5
and without it
the floodgates open completely rook
takes b5
so how does this work
so
okay so so obviously you have to take
the rook because otherwise he takes b2
if you take it with the knight that
there's nothing to discuss he plays
queen takes c4 and he attacks both the
rook and the knight with check
so you have to take the work of the pawn
now the c file opens
now the tempting move i think for a lot
of people would be rook check but this
is a very big mistake because this
allows the king to hide
to to hide on b1
so instead of going rook check he goes
queen c4 check which forks the king and
the rook forces the king to move into d2
and obviously now you can already tell
that there's all sorts of moves here
but my opponent continues to play
incredible moves he finds another
excellent move
now he's got a draw in his pocket if he
wants it he can give me a check and he
can repeat moves i was hoping for that
but i also knew that he wasn't gonna go
for a draw here
um he brings his knight back to d7
attacking the queen
and also preparing to move into c5
so
believe it or not there's like no good
squares for a white's queen no matter
where you go
there's either a fork
or there's some tactic the queen has
absolutely no good squares
so for example if you go queen e4 then
there's knight c5 of the fork this loses
on the spot
if you go queen g3 then there's again
knight c5 and again you cannot move the
rook because you lose the other knight
and 94 check is a fork that's being
threatened
if you go
queen e1
then again there's knight c5 and
that's the recurring problem
so i went queenie two
and my idea was to allow knight f4
and then go up to e3 and i was trying to
like give up the exchange strategically
but force him to trade in the exchange
for the attack
so he played knight f4
i played queen e3 he repeated moves once
which gave me some hope
but then he took on g2
and i i have no choice but to go queen
e2 he goes back to f4 so he wins upon
and uh
here i think he makes
a serious mistake
so i feel like the fastest
winning move black has several ways to
win this game to win this position
and the way that he played preserves the
decisive advantage but it may it's the
wind starts getting more complicated the
way that he played it
so he has this very zen move e5
and the idea is actually quite simple
you're attacking the knight
and if the knight moves then you take on
v5 you don't worry about taking the rook
because the knight is actually stronger
than the rope
so e5 and queen takes b5 in the game is
over like
white loses everything queen takes b2 is
coming the knight is saying the rook is
hanging the other knight's coming in
this is like minus five because it's a
zen move because you don't take the rook
you like just accumulate the attack with
the movie five
but
he
went knight d5 he went back to d5
i went back to e2
he gives me a check on b4 remember this
check
now there's a very nice line you have to
decide whether you go to c2 or c1
um
king c1 loses straightforwardly
and i know he was hoping for this i
didn't play king c1 this loses on the
spot
and what does it lose to it loses to
knight f4 again
queen e3 again
but this time he takes the rook finally
and does anybody see
what the winning continuation here is
for black
why does king why does the placement of
the king on c1 hurt white so much
because it seems like the most
relatively safest place to put the k
no not rook c8 again roxy it's same
problem
can be owned or even knight c6
no rook c8 there's even knight c6
blocking the check and white is okay
because b5 is defended
yeah knight c5
and for example queen e3 and queen takes
d4
bang
yeah exactly
and then you win
the queen back when you're up at night
yeah so he was hoping for this but i
didn't do it i played king c2 yeah but
rook c8 is actually very counter
productive it allows king v1
this is where he had his second winning
move and if he found this move white can
basically resign and that's the smooth
a3 i saw this move during the game i was
just praying he wouldn't play it i
actually saw this move
it's less
complicated than it seems this move so
what does this move do well it threatens
queen takes v2 check which is crushing
totally
you can't take with the rook because you
dropped the knight this probably is what
white should do but
with two knights and a wide open king
it's like minus five black should win
this without too much trouble
now if you take with a pawn you're like
well what does black accomplish finally
it's time to give the check on c8 and
now you can see why a3 was played you
have covered the b file with the queen
the king is forced in the other
direction
and it is torn apart by black's pieces
queen b1 check etc i mean
at a absolute minimum you can take the
rook and you're completely winning
you're up a piece and you're made
there's more effectiveness so a3
0 1 basically
another winning move here was to play
knight c5 and the pressure is
overwhelming
this was also winning
but my opponent with
six more moves to make until time patrol
he was at a little time pressure and he
decided to
to play it simple he played knight f4
and at this when he played this move i
realized that i'm gonna have chances to
to hold
queen d2 he takes the rook so he trades
the attack in for a material advantage
he goes 95
improves his knight queen c3 and queen
takes d6 so he transitions to this
position where
in white's position sucks the king is
still weak i'm down upon
his pieces are perfectly positioned
and
white's drawing chances are are slim but
i figured that if i could
stir up some counter play maybe i could
use the past b-pawn
i also saw this pattern that
if i could get his knight off of e5 i
would have knight c6 maybe 97 checkmate
in some positions
could be an idea and so i played f4
i tried to force his knight off of e5 so
that i could stick my knight on c6
but now he finds another accurate move i
mean he was playing incredible this game
other than bishop d7 he played an
incredible game does anybody remember or
see
what black can do that doesn't involve
moving the knight he did not move the
knight from e5
he found a much better move
a queen d7
ah no queen i see what you want but it
doesn't work is it white remember white
always says knight c6
no it's not going to be 7.
i i had a feeling somebody would say
rook d8 but this is also not right
because remember
if you get into a rook end game this
pawn is going to be very very dangerous
black's king is on the opposite side of
the board
so this is the worst case scenario for
black where you left this pawn alive and
it's anybody in fact the engine is
showing that white is winning already
so you don't want to trade everything
yeah queen d5
attacking the rook on h1
now you might be like big [ __ ] you know
attacking the rook what's the what like
why is this a problem
it's a problem because the knight on e5
now has
the c4 square and that's a much more
dangerous square than d7
so also the other problem is that if you
go rook d1 which is the most natural
move
then black has queen e4 checks forking
the king and the pawn
so that's another huge problem
this is out of the question
so you have to go rook e1 which is
awkward because the rook on e1 is not
particularly good
okay knight c4
and now
i was at first planning to play knight
c6
but this is a one-trick pony this
threatens checkmate and if black
prevents it white has no more moves
b5 is hanging
and if you lose this pawn you can resign
the game if you lose the b5 pawn
then you have nothing left to play for
you're just down two pawns of the
terrible king
so
i was really happy with the way that i
played the next
i
i i think the way i played the rest of
the game even though it wasn't flawless
was
as good as it gets defensively i mean i
found every little way to challenge him
and not make it easy
so the first thing i did was i didn't
panic in this position i took about
five minutes and i realized that like
okay black doesn't have any threats
currently so
what i can do is i can take the one
tempo i have to improve my position
slightly
what does it mean to improve your
position well
the king on c2 to me was the weak link
like this king is terribly placed it's
right in the middle of everything so i
decided to drop it back to b1
i figured at least
at least the king is a little bit safer
on b1
so i have a slightly bigger chance of
not getting mated if it's on b1
okay so black brings this rook into the
game rook d8
and now i have to go to c6 knight c6
and this is a very interesting moment
because
if you look carefully you'll find
that black has this move 90 to check
which looks incredibly scary when i was
calculating it from a distance i thought
it was winning for black but then i
realized it's not
kiko king a1
now black swings the knight around to b3
you go king b1
and at first i thought that this was
checkmate
it does look like checkmate takes takes
king a2 rook a1
but miraculously it's not king c2 rook
c1 is not mate you go king d3 and it's
not even a draw black just loses here
because black will not be able to stop
this pawn
and by the way black white can also go
king a2 here
and
again the king is uncatchable because it
has a3
so
somehow the king on b1 is actually
surprisingly safe this is only like
minus 1.5
and i calculated this crazy line
so i figured black has to go rook d7
then i thought i'd swing my knight back
to e5
and after rook b7 it looks like
finally black has surrounded the pawn
black is going to win the pawn on b5 and
once black wins the pawn on b5 we have
established that the game is basically
over
but out of nowhere white has a lovely
move here
which i found during the game i
calculated this line accurately and it's
knight e5 to g4
and all of a sudden this is a pattern
you should be familiar with white
threatens knight f6 and knight h6
but i hear you saying doesn't this win
the night queen f5 check is a fork but
if you keep calculating
go king a2
if black takes on g4
we have a fork of our own queen ca check
forks the king and the rock
and i confirmed that this line was
accurately calculated
and if he takes on b5
well if he takes the rook then you walk
into the fork this is all very simple
if he takes with the queen then already
i can still give a check on f6
and now i have a move such as rook d1
and i come coming into d8 white is
already winning here
so this was good calculation
unfortunately none of this happened
because rather than checking me on d2
black played the immediate rook d7
now i don't have any choice but to go
back to e5 anyway
and i was really really hoping
that he would not take the knight here i
was hoping that he would play knight d2
and transpose back into
that line
that's what i was really hoping for
uh slim thank you
so unfortunately after about 15 minutes
of thought and
the time control for this event was you
had a hundred minutes so an hour 40
for 40 moves and then there was an
additional 30 minutes that were added
when you made move 40 this is move 42
and then there was a 30 second increment
all throughout
so at this point he's got maybe 15
minutes for the rest of the game which
gave me some more hope knight takes e5
okay rook takes e5 and now he gives me
a check on d1
now he gives me a check on d1
so there was another incredible line
here i don't know if this is interesting
if he goes queen h1 check i calculated
the following line
so
if king c2 you get checkmated
immediately okay
if king a2 then black doubles on the
first rank and i figured that this would
be a huge threat i didn't like the look
of this either
but there is a third move that white has
which is to drop the rook back to e1
now this attacks the queen right
white is threatening queen ca with a
fork
but if you look carefully you might find
that black has a move that seems to lead
to a winning queen end game does anybody
see it rook d1
and i was calculating that and i was
like no
takes d1 queen takes d1 now this
wouldn't be a problem if white could
keep the b-pawn i don't give a damn that
i'm down upon it's not about who's down
upon the queen and against it's about
who's got the passer but
after king a2 he's got the fork queen d5
forking the king and the pawn
but you cannot stop calculating here and
here white has a brilliant resource that
i think gives white
sufficient counter play to make a draw
does anybody see it yeah you play this
move b3
and the point is the following if black
takes on b3 then it's all very simple
you play queen takes b3 you're defending
the bomb
if black takes on b5 then you simply
advance your pawn to v4
and because of this past pawn and
because of the pawn on f4 being a
giga chat and stopping
all of black's pawn majority i think
white is able to draw this because
you're basically going to go k3
and queen c5 you're going to dislodge
the queen from b5
and if black is not careful he could
even lose this because the king is so
far away from the b-pawn
so i calculated this line
and
i was like okay please play queen h1 and
go for this but of course he calculated
it too and he played queen d1 check
which is much more accurate
okay king a2 and rook d3 was his idea
and this is a lot scarier
than the other line
now in this position i find it only move
every other move loses very very quickly
now most of you are probably like okay
queen c8 check right but queen c8
doesn't do anything he just
shifts his king up to g7 and there's a
devastating threat of queen b3 check
followed by a checkmate on d1
but as some of you guys are pointing out
you have this crazy move rookie one
miraculously this holds
or at least it keeps the game going and
it basically forces an end game
rookie one attacking the queen
so
if he takes on c3 we take on d1 this is
very similar to what happened in the
game
so in the game he gives a check on v3 he
tries to get the best possible version
of the end game
and
essentially here
the king is boxed in so if you try to
cling
to the b5 pawn
that's not a successful strategy because
eventually black's gonna set his
kingside pawns in motion it'll take a
couple of moves but it'll happen
and there's just nothing that white can
do here if you try to move your kang
back around
you only just walk into a3
yeah i think this is still winning for
black but it's but it's very complicated
even with an engine
but fortunately you can go after the a
pawn you go rookie four
rook takes b5 or takes a4 and i realize
this is as close as i had been to making
a draw in like 25 moves
because black is up upon
and i realized that what is probably
going to happen is is that black is
probably going to play e5 and get rid of
the f1 black is going to have like
a three on one situation on the king
side
and i'm gonna have this pass b pawn
which i'm gonna start pushing
um and this b-bond is
a huge trump card especially because
black's king as we have established is
very very far away
so black plays rook f5
and here i took about 10 minutes because
i was trying to figure out
like a couple of things it's very
complicated
the first
my first temptation was actually to play
b4 which is not such a stupid move rook
takes out give up the pawn i don't give
a bit about it looking b3 and quickly
push b5
so this is my first inclination but i
figured this was going a little bit too
far
i figured that giving up a third pawn on
the king side
uh just my intuition ruled it out
but i still need to analyze this with an
engine i still haven't analyzed this
properly then i came up with a better
idea i was like wait a second
what i can do is i can move my rook to
either d4 or c4
and what this does is it prepares the
move b4
but it also cuts off the black king
in both rook c4 and rook d4 this cuts
the king off along the c file rook d4
cuts the king along the d file and it
ensures that the black king cannot get
past
you know the center so the b pawn is
going to be
is going to have a pretty clear path
forward
does the logic i hope the logic makes
sense so at that point i was trying to
decide between rook c4 and rogue d4
which is like a ridiculously hard
decision
and
the the way that i made this decision
apparently according to the engine rook
d4 is a cleaner
is already a draw
but the reason that i
didn't play rook d4 is i calculated the
following line so i thought black would
play e5
we would trade i would start pushing and
black would start pushing
and you cannot get the spawn to b5
without
the king's assistance so you have to go
king b3 it's not efficient but you have
to do it
then i figured black will go g5
okay we have to keep
helping the pawn along
f4 b5
f3
and here i committed a mistake in my
calculation i thought that b6 is forced
i thought that b6 is forced and
hopefully you can't you can't really
blame you for that
but b6 actually loses because white
black plays f2
now if you go b7 black queens with check
and you might say well no problem let's
just stop the pawn but then black has
rookie one
but then black is ricky one
and
again black promotes a check
so then i thought well wait a second
wait a second i don't have to go king c4
right
i can also go king a4 get the same exact
thing
but not have to worry about black
promoting with check but
then again i started calculating and i
figured okay
f4
b5 f3 b6 f2
b7
rookie a
and
here i made a an epic i had an epiphany
and i said wait wait a second if my rook
was on c4 instead of d4 in this exact
position i imagine this position but
white's rook was on c4 what would white
have in this position does anybody see
if the work was on c4 and it's an
obvious question
i hope that this makes an iota of sense
by the way
yeah rex c8 right you would have rook ca
let's just for the sake of illustration
let's say the rook was here you would
have to move rook c8
and in fact black has to be very careful
because f1 queen you take on the inn and
you make a queen and only white can win
that
only white can win that
so on the basis of that
i decided all this way back that i would
play rook c4 instead of rook d4
but
i forgot to check well okay i understood
that there is a drawback
of rook c4 in comparison to rook d4
which is that it allows black's king to
get a little bit closer to the pawn
but i figured since i'm cutting the king
off along the c file even if the king
reaches the d6 square it's not going to
be a problem it's not going to hamper
the fund's progress and that's where i
was wrong
but here's what happens he goes king f8
i push
he goes king e7
again we've reached the same problem
where you can't play b5 so you have to
bring i have to bring my own king up
king b3
so he did bring his king up to d6 okay i
go king a4
and now as expected he goes e5 he has to
play this move otherwise he's never
going to start pushing his king side
pawns thank you kiddo deezy
we trade and we get this type of
position
so i push b5
and here i completely underestimated
like i just didn't see
the move that he played from a distance
i i totally ignored it and that's the
move rook e5 to e2
and here i started understanding that
there was a big problem
and the problem is as follows
so
you might be looking this is saying well
why why can't y just push b6
and you actually can push b6
um but
i figured that here black will play rook
takes h2
and if you play b7
then black plays rook b2 and this is
where the placement of black's king on
d6 is such a huge problem if the king
was on e7 then we would be able to play
rook b4 and white would actually be
winning
but now there's always going to be rook
takes before and king c7 the king is
close enough to the pawn where if a
moment the white's rook leaves the c
file and you have to leave the c file
eventually
the king will be able to stop the pawn
and this is the detail that i missed now
analyzing with an engine i realize how
much of a fool i am
because in this position
white actually draws with a super calm
move king a4 to b3 stopping rook b2
and the best that black can do is just
go rook h1 king b2 rook h2 check and you
get a repetition of moves because
neither side can deviate from it
so it turns out that i actually should
have played v6 and b6
comes close to drawing the game i think
it does draw the game
but instead i thought that i have to
defend this pawn so i played h4
does not give away the draw
apparently
okay so he starts pushing he goes f5
i go b6
he stops my pawn with rook b2 i defend
the pawn with king a5 so again again
rook b4 it loses to rook takes before in
king c6 and this is a lost end game
so i have to use my king here to stop to
to to defend the plot
so
what do you think my opponent did in
this position
there's really only one thing that black
can do in order to make progress on the
king's side because he can't play f4
he can't play g5 he needs to prepare g5
he plays h6
and this is a fascinating moment this
might be the most interesting one of the
whole game
so
what is white's most tempting move let's
start by discussing the most tempting
one
yeah so well i mean you you want to push
your pawn you can't push
right
and i started calculating black goes g5
and i'm sure you guys have seen end
games like this where
essentially white is going to spend a
bunch of tempi to promote the pawn black
is going to give the rook away for the
pawn and then the two passers are going
to overwhelm white stroke you know what
i'm talking about this is a classic
scenario
and i thought that this scenario would
unfold in this position that white would
lose
and what i calculated was king a7 or
sorry i guess white should start with b7
f4 king a7 this is not such a
complicated line f3
b8 queen
takes takes
f2
rook c1 g4 and black
obviously wins and this is not even
close actually
but
the thing with like engines is like
engines are very good at finding these
like
ridiculous moves so here for example
right
can you blame me for assuming that b7 is
forced
like that
how can it not be but apparently the
draw is given
by the move rook c8
the point
is not to play b7 that's not the point
of this move
the point of this move
is that after f4 all of a sudden you
switch gears and you play rook g8
attacking the pawn on g5
and black does not have the bandwidth to
defend that pawn if black tries to
defend it and there's only one way to
then you play b7 and black is
torn in two different directions
if black plays f3 then you are in time
to take the pawn and stop the other pawn
as well and this is a draw
now black can play a little bit more
cleverly with g4
because if you try to repeat the
strategy and go rook f8 now the king can
defend the other pawn
but here you play like a computer now
you play b7
black plays g3 and continuous pushing
and amazingly
you can play b8 queen and this is a draw
i can't believe it either this position
is a draw
and here's why this is a draw so
if black plays g2 then black loses the
pawn immediately right
so what would you guys do here for black
you would play f4 right
now white still plays rook g8
and the rub is that black cannot push
the f pawn because he gives up the g1
and the king cannot efficiently get to a
spot where it defends the g3 pawn
because the pawns are in the way
so black for example plays king e5 and
now we start bringing our own king king
b5
king 4 king c4
now there's a beautiful detail here
so hopefully you understand where this
is going black has this very tricky move
f3
can anybody tell me how white draws in
this position
because there's a just a gorgeous little
detail
what you do not do is rook takes g3 this
is a classic idea the pawn is
unstoppable
you play rook g4 check first that's the
point
if the king steps forward then you take
on g3
and you pin the pawn if the king steps
backward then you can already stop the
pawn via f3
just remember this trick by the way rook
g4 check you like
land once one square before the pawn
if black plays king f3
then he blocks his other pawn
and this is a draw rook g6 king e4
and that's it you can just do nothing
black is just not able to make any
progress eventually you get two kings
so
on the basis of this extremely simple
line
this idea of actually stopping the pawns
from behind rook c8 was the drawing move
i did not see that
i thought the desperate measures were
necessary and i found what i thought was
a beautiful idea
i played the move rook c4 to f4
and at this point my opponent has like
three minutes and i have maybe 10.
so my idea is actually very very similar
i'm trying to prevent g5 trying to
prevent g5
and i'm trying to provoke the move king
e5 in which case i would now go rook b4
and now the king is too far away if he
takes it he actually loses king d6 king
b5
f4 not b7 because of king c7 king a6 f3
b7
this is uh featured in my endgame videos
is the type of pawn race where white
promotes the check
just beautiful study like ideas but
that's that's not the that's just the
tip of the iceberg
now it may seem
that
king c5
wins the game for black on the spot
right because this threatens a gazillion
things it threatens rook a2 check which
is not made because the rook can block
the check but it also threatens like
rugby five check it threatens just to
take the pawn on v6 it looks like the
game is over but this is where i set a
trap and i came up with the idea of
playing h5 in this position
and it this looks so winning for black
but i actually think it's
it's 50 50. it's very close to a draw
if rook a2 check
i play rook a4
and if he takes it you get a beautiful
position where because i put this
kamikaze pawn on h5 black is overwhelmed
you can't stop both at the same time b7
is threatened
and if you take the pawn then the other
pawn promotes
crazy idea thank you claudio
but the secondary point of this move is
that if he takes on v6 then we take on
g6
and now we break apart his pawn chain
and after rook takes g6 rook takes f5
you get this end game
which i will need to plug this into
table base
or maybe somebody can do that
i do not know if this is a win or a draw
but i figured that in a game i would
have very good drawing chances here i
would park my rook
in front of the pawn
and
okay
the chestnut comment gives like minus
two but that's totally meaningless it's
either winning or it's a draw
basically you get a scenario where white
tries to bring his king all the way back
toward f1
yeah minus 3.7 is meaningless that
you have to understand in such positions
like there's only two evaluations either
winning or it's a draw
table base says black is winning so
apparently this was still winning for
black thank you for plugging it in
looks like white's king does not get
close in time this is something i'll
analyze separately but it doesn't matter
right now the fact of the matter is i
did enough to scare him
he told me after the game that he made a
brief judgment this was a draw
and so
what he ends up doing is he plays king
c6 rook c4 check he repeats moves once
and then he plays the move h5
and i consider this to be a huge win
because if he plays a tribe that means
that he can no longer play g5 he can no
longer create connected passives
but obviously that's not the end of the
story because he can still use his king
to help his existing passer forward
and i figured what i need to do is i
need to go after the g pawn as quickly
as i can so i moved my rook back to f1
and this is perhaps the most beautiful
moment of the whole end game this is
where and those of you who are watching
the official us test stream you will
know that black has it
this is honestly one of the most
stunning endgame ideas i have ever seen
i'm not even exaggerating
there is only one winning move for black
only one
if you would have found it i would have
probably gotten the arbiter
it's an unbelievable move so
obviously my opponent played the natural
move which was king e4 and the game ends
in a draw
no it's not if he moves this king to the
c file then we just give a check and
we're we're chilling
we're chilling
yeah so the correct move
is f4
giving up the only pass pawn
that he has f4
and what the hell rook takes that f4 it
almost looks like white's better
but black plays king c5 and this reveals
the idea of f4 the idf is to put the
rook on the most inconvenient position
on the whole board you don't have a
check on f5
and the main thing is that you no longer
have a check down the c file
and white's king is screwed
now it's not checkmate that black
threads black does not threaten
checkmate black threatens
uh to win the spawn and then to use his
pawn majority to win the game
so for example let's say that white
plays a pass move like rookie four
so taking immediately
is a draw because white has this check
on e5
and this is another beautiful idea white
plays rookie five check
it seems like black is fine we go king
d4 and we counter attack the rook who
can tell me what the drawing move here
is for white
another incredible idea
rook takes h5 desperado sack
and the king is just in time by one
tempo just in time
to reach the corner you by the way you
can also play king f4 of course which is
also draw
so for that reason black has this it's
the same concept by the way you put the
rook one square in front of the pawn
this forces the king either to move into
the check
or to move back in either case the rook
can take on b6 and apparently according
to gary this is a winning end game for
play it doesn't surprise me because the
white king is cut off on the worst
possible file
and black will just sort of inch his
king to closer and closer to white spawn
and eventually black is going to find a
way to win white spawn on h4 this is
winning there's no way that i would have
held this in the game
there's no way
um so the move f4 is the only winning
move in this position you sack the pawn
and then you play king c5 ridiculous
my opponent plays king e4
the funny thing is
okay so i gave him a bunch of checks
the point is that i force his king to
step in front of the pawn that gives me
a critical tempo
and what do i do with this tempo i take
one pawn
and here i had to avoid one final
pitfall here i had to avoid one final
pitfall
my first inclination
was to basically go like rook f6
and then to go
king a6
and then in this position
i was like okay i can go rook g6 check
and
i can
like any time he moves away from the
pawn i can go back to f6
and this looks like a draw but it's
actually not because what black can do
here
is go king f3 king e2
king d1
you have to go back to f6 then the king
steps into e1
and if you go rookie six check black
plays rook e2
now you might look at this and say well
no problem right you take on e2
and we both promote and it's a drop but
it's not a draw if you watch my end game
videos you should recognize this pattern
it's the skewer pattern black gives a
check on the a file check on the b file
trades queens and wins the resulting
plot end game
so
for that reason if we rewind back to
this moment it is critical for white to
still play accurately
rook g5 is the most accurate move i
played it and this draws on the spot
because in the time that black takes to
move his king away i have the time to
take his remaining pawn
and park my rook behind his spawn
and that's it this is a dead draw
because at this point if black promotes
i don't even care i can just take the
pawn and promote the b-pawn
in fact i declined the draw here which
is kind of funny and i played king a6
but then i realized this is actually a
dead draw because black can just play f1
queen
and this is a bedrock because if i go b7
like black can just check me a bunch of
times and
go king f4 and stop the other pawn so
i didn't i decided not to uh
you know play with him any further
and at this point i was like so happy
that i could make a draw i didn't want
to like
test my luck
and i took the draw
and that's how i saved uh this
ridiculously lost position the last
round
and i i am very very pissed that i
didn't play bishop g5 this was a a
mental breakdown that is totally
unacceptable
completely unacceptable laziness
and that lays in has directly led to me
losing uh or
should have led to me losing
um
should have found this move but
it was one mistake and i made several
smaller mistakes in this
early middle game phase all credit to my
opponent for like
unbelievable play and
lovely move a4 rook a5 queen c5 i mean
he played like a 2700 in this stretch
and then
obviously after rook b5 at this point i
knew i i was 100 sure i was going to
lose the game
but didn't panic like force myself to
find
resilient defensive ideas and ultimately
it paid off
yeah it's a completely different feeling
to like not lose the last game i would
have been in a much worse mood i don't
know if anybody's interested in
20 more minutes of analysis i i can show
the ending of my fourth round game
against the cobian
in this game we followed my against
caron of as championship for a while
so he outplays me completely
yeah let me get to the sort of first
critical moment
so the upshot is that i had to give up
my queen after 25 moves to reach this
position
black has and let's flip the board
because that was black black has a a
rook and a piece for the queen actually
does not look that bad
if you look superficially and black's
pieces look kind of nice
but in this position white has a winning
sequence white has a sequence of two
moves that ends the game actually just
ends the game
does anybody see it
it i know it sounds weird to say because
like it seems like everything is
defended for black but it's an illusion
does anybody see what my opponent should
have done here
so he should have started by taking the
knight yes that's correct but that's the
easy part right i mean obviously
everybody sees that
what what is the follow this is what he
missed yeah in knight d4
knight f3 goes to d4 like what does this
do well obviously this attacks the
bishop i mean he threatens to take twice
on c6
and that's the problem right if you move
the bishop
then he dives in
through c7 and black's position
collapses here completely because you're
losi i mean your bishop is nowhere good
to go
and if you go rook f7 here the queen
drops back to b6 and you also lose the
e6 pawn
so this is a complete disaster i would
have resigned in a couple of moves that
he played this but he didn't find it he
thought for like 20 minutes and he
didn't find this
i was shocked he played knight d2
this gave me a glimmer of foe and i
started out playing him
so
i was out playing him and eventually we
started repeating moves
we were repeating moves i was sure that
he would take a draw
but all of a sudden he goes for it he
goes bishop c4 in this position
which is a really bad move because at
this point my pieces are so active that
it's not worth for white to not repeat
and i continue to outplay he like panics
completely he gives up a pawn
and
then we reach and then he blunders again
and then we reach this position so this
this is the the second critical moment
so
black is winning
black is winning but
a couple of precise moves are still
required
so the tempting idea is to play rook d
d2 right and threaten checkmate on h2
why is this flawed well this is flawed
because black why does this check on an
ada you have to cover that check and in
so doing
you are giving away the g1 square so
rook h2 is no longer checkmate white has
this very annoying move e6
and it gets really complicated right
so okay
now
the the move that wins the game
straightforwardly i saw that move is to
get the knight through g7 to h5 knight
h5 yeah
you are threatening checkmate in one
move white has to drop his queen back
and among other things and king a chain
is winning everything is winning but
even rook d2 is still winning
even this is winning
because although queen takes f7 looks
scary if you actually calculate which i
did not do at all
after king h8
this square is defended this square is
defended queenie h king g7
and it doesn't matter rook f7 or queen
f7 the king escapes to h6
where it is safe and now checkmate is
unstoppable
beautiful line isn't it
it's gorgeous how the king escapes the
checks i mean white can go like this
and then like this but this is only
staves off the checkmate
so this would have caused immediate
resignation
so i saw this and the line that i saw is
knight h5 queen f3 and king hha just get
out of the check also winning this also
would have led to insta resign
but why would you play like a normal
civilized person right why would you not
try to be fancy and ruin everything so i
was about to play that h5 then i was
like wait a second i think i see an even
better move
i saw the move knight f5
and the point is that after bishop takes
f5 now you play rook d2
again checkmate is threatened and the
point of knight f5 is actually to create
luft for the king on g7 and after king
g7 white runs out of checks
and his check mated
so
i thought about it for a couple minutes
i thought let's
finish the game in style
i played knight f5 turns out that this
takes the position from like minus 11 to
to equal
yeah he takes with the rook
instead of the bishop and i saw this
that's the craziest part this is what
i'm going to have to figure out after
the turbine why did i see this and still
went for it
because after gf5 queen f5
what i calculated during the game i
thought well
i give him a check
this is not mate he has bishop f1
and then i thought i'd go
rook bb1
and i thought that i win his bishop and
i'm gonna be up a gazillion pieces
and what i calculated was that he gives
me a check on g5
and i escaped to f8
and i thought that the king escapes the
checks
what i had missed
and what i had completely missed
is that rather than giving me a check on
g5 he can check me on g4
and after king f8 queen ca check
and you cannot run to e7 you drop the
bishop with check
and you cannot run to h6 because you get
checkmated this is a perpetual
all of a sudden i started getting
nervous i'm like
this has to be winning i'm like one step
away from mating him he's got a couple
of checks so i said no problem you know
what i'll do what i'll do is i'll go
bishop back to e7
and i was happy with this move during
the game this covers the g5 story he was
threatening queen g5
and queen g4 check is totally innocuous
you just go king f8 or king h8 the king
escapes the checks
but
what it's amazing is what how white
manages to start a fire on the king side
out of nothing
what did my opponent do in this position
and there's not much though i could do
white e6 e6 you've got to open [ __ ] up
on the king side right
and if f takes c6 then queen takes c6
king f8 queen h6
and again white forces a drop
and if black goes f6 which was my
initial idea
then the queen jumps to h5 and all of a
sudden
notice how beautifully the queen covers
d1 and threatens queen f7 and
black threatens bishop f5
and that actually leads to checkmate to
the black king
so that's out of the question fe is out
of the question what the hell does black
do so i had like five minutes on my
clock and eventually i come up with this
idea to play c3
i i think this is a really cool concept
because if queen takes f7 as scary as
this looks the king is actually safe
here remember white cannot take on e7
because now he gets checkmated
now he gets checkmated
and if bishop f5 again he gets check
minutes so this rook d1 threat is really
strong and of course there's also the
threat of just promoting the pawn going
c2 and c1
so i thought c3 was winning
and if he plays e takes f7 then you hide
behind the pawn and again i was sure the
black is winning
but my opponent finds a brilliant move
it's a prophylactic move right what is
black's threat well black's threat is to
give a check on d1 or to play c2 and c1
with check
so he plays an incredibly calm move what
did he play
not king g1 that doesn't help bishop f1
king g1 doesn't actually help because it
walks right into more checks
bishop f1 only move
and
you're like well why is this a good move
like what what the hell well
let's consider the move c2
well now
it's not that c1 queen isn't a threat
it's that c1 queen does not come with
check anymore so white can just do his
thing and take all my pieces after c1
queen
at the very least white has a perpet but
it turns out actually that white is
winning after queen takes the a check
which is crazy
that white is winning in some of these
lines
so you can't play c2
um
there's not much else you can do if you
play f6 then we already know the joke
when h5 and white wins
so
it dawned on me that there's nothing i
can do
other than f takes c6 and we've already
established that this is a perpetual
queen h6 check and the queen easily
pursues the king all throughout the port
but i was so devastated that i had given
up the win after such a crazy comeback
that i just went on tilt
i went until and i was like i'm gonna go
go for it anyway when king e8
and king d7 and this is totally brazen
because i'm also walking into some
bishop checks potentially
but my opponent plays action then i play
bishop d6
queen b7 check
and rather than going back to c7 or that
bishop i went king yay
and after queen c6 i was like oh [ __ ] i
might actually lose the pawn and not
only might i lose the pawn i might lose
the pawn with a fork and now i'm in
serious danger of losing
so i went king f8
and to my relief my opponent went back
to f3
and it turns out that queen takes c3 is
actually winning
rook f2 and now this move bishop g2
according to the engine is winning for
white it's like plus four
crazy the king is just stranded and
queen h8 is coming and there are too
many third the point of bishop g2
is
so that you'll have bishop d5 check if
the king tries to hide on g8
by miracle my opponent doesn't play it
he goes queen f3 queen e5 and finally he
starts repeating moves
and i was like okay this is terrible
this is devastating but at least
at least i didn't lose
but then all of a sudden my opponent
thinks until he has two minutes on the
clock
and he plays queen f6
and i looked at this for a second i said
there's no way that he just did that i
must be dreaming
because this is one of the worst
blunders that have ever been committed
against me
what is wrong with this move who can
tell me
who can tell me
yeah simply rook f8
white has one check
the king escapes to h8 and that's it the
king is perfectly safe and black wins
because like you're now threatening c2
and all the old stuff the king is now
safe
now i don't know if he forgot that he
didn't have this check maybe
maybe it was that he told me something
after the game i didn't buy it
i mean he just went completely crazy
queen f6 for cafe
it was
yeah king h8
c2 and i won
i promoted to a queen
now i easily escape the checks
and he resigned in this position
he told me that he
halluci like he saw a cafe earlier and
then forgot about it is what he told me
but like i mean this move attacks my
rook what do you expect me to do
i don't know what he was expecting i
really don't know i mean the rook is
literally attacked i have to move it
maybe he thought the bishop was on g2
you know it can be a lot of different
things
you can never like explain these types
of hallucinations so this guy's level
he's about 2300 feet a obviously
extremely underrated he is the son of
vladimir kopian who is a very strong gem
who is also playing this tournament
armenian
his usdf is about 2 400. so i mean his
rating is high but
my guess is that he's easily i am
strength at least
so it was satisfying to win this game
but like
way too many mistakes and i got really
really lucky and then i won a really
nice game in the next round
which was my smoothest game in the
tournament
and also my strongest win
and after that the draws began but again
i think if i had to draw conclusions
from this tournament early conclusions
obviously my openings are a disaster
like i
this game i was i was minus four out of
the opening
even even this last game was josh like i
i was totally
lacking confidence in the opening
against el shawn i played into a line
that i didn't know and i was already
worse by move 15 where i offered to draw
so
openings are a big problem and then like
just lapses in concentration there were
just moments when i lost my
concentration and played really dumb
moves which were inexcusable like
missing bishop g5 against josh
there were a lot of things that i did
wrong this tournament but the good news
is that i didn't lose any games it was
solid i think i still
i'm keeping my level intact which is
which is a good thing so
[Music]